you
[Music]
okay it's my honor today to introduce
Susan Athey she's the economics of
Technology professor at the Stanford
Graduate School of Business
Susan received her bachelor's degree
from Duke and a PhD at Stanford not to
be outdone by that do gave her an
honorary PhD degree or doctorate
Susan's research focuses on the
intersection of machine learning and
econometrics marketplace design and the
economics of digitization she advises
governments and businesses on
marketplace design and platform
economics and I remember we first heard
of heard met her when she came in as in
2007 or so has Microsoft's chief
economist you call it Consulting chief
economist and as a a preview of the
forthcoming fireside chat which was this
this time today featured early filmed
earlier than in the this distinguished
lecture Susan mentioned that Steve
Ballmer at the time said he's having it
was interested in learning more about
this online stuff and you'll hear more
about that when you see the fireside
chat
Susan was elected to the National
Academy of Science in 2012 and the
American Academy of Arts and Sciences
does an 8
she's taught in the economics department
at MIT Stanford and Harvard in 2007
susan was awarded the James John Bates
Clark medal this is the is known as the
the Nobel Prize for a younger economists
and in this case under 40 and yeah I
guess you're still under 40 which is
great and today she's be speaking about
large scale models of consumer choice
and counterfactual inference a really
interesting area and with implications
not just for services but for core
economic economic and electric models
and even biology I think so take it away
great thanks so much
so I'm delighted to be here at MSR and
really it's wonderful to be back and see
old friends and particularly people who
really introduced me to this whole
research agenda so I started in my
relationship with Microsoft started in
2007 and I was brought in at that point
because I knew things about marketplace
design and auctions and Microsoft
realized that they just kind of built up
the search engine and they were trying
they really hadn't started optimizing
the ad platform for the search engine at
all and they also had a lot of strategic
questions about how to compete with
Google and so on and so I came in but I
had no experience with with working with
companies or with engineering I didn't
know what what machine learning meant
and I had never worked with large scale
systems and some since I was a baby
along with Bing ads because at the time
I came in in order to analyze the data
from Bing ads which at that point we
called ad center you actually had to
take a PC there was a woman named Susan
Ong and she had to take her take a PC
and like spend the entire weekend
copying the files onto a hard drive
which they then FedEx to me in the nice
in in in New England and then I I worked
with that data so I actually provided
some of the first insights about Bing
ads because I was the first one who
could actually break the data into
deciles or send tiles because actually
the computing infrastructure didn't
exist there to actually do that and so
we kind of were grew up alongside the
building the infrastructure to optimize
the the system and it was really
exciting to be there in those early days
when everything was new and and every
insight every insight you brought from
data could really be be put into great
action so in those in those early days I
was thinking of thinking that what I
could bring to bear was things about
economics and and how advertiser
behavior because a lot of the engineers
who had been brought in came from other
products and Microsoft and so they you
know there was this big order database
where people put their bids for for
search auctions but those those they
there was no real reason you had to
think about those as active active
participants but
the database was just sitting there so
it's easy to abstract from away from
even the idea that you had customers so
I was trying to bring in kind of
economic ideas there and I would say
things like hey you guys you know if we
if we reduce the quality of the ads or
if we raise the prices the advertisers
might not buy as much and there would be
a little bit of pushback like well
where's the evidence for that and
actually it turned out in some sense
it's not true because if the order
database is fixed and you query it in
it won't go order database won't change
and sent aeneas lee so you had to think
about different forms of analytics as
well as different ways to experiment to
really get at that advertiser behavior
so as I started trying to dig into this
I started realizing that although I had
sort of great insights about how to do
empirical analysis on small data sets
from economics there was so much that I
really was not prepared to do with these
larger data sets and and being one
economist in a team of you know all the
engineers were coming from engineering
disciplines and the MSR people who I was
able to collaborate with they're all
coming from computer science disciplines
I needed to in order to do these
empirical projects I really needed to
become bilingual and so that was an
amazing experience for me and actually
Patrice is here we had these early
arguments where we kind of you know
really were like clashing you know and
there's a sense of like I was an
economist I'm like I've been doing
empirical work my whole life you know of
course like I know how to do this and
Patrice's like well we've been doing
machine learning you know we know how to
do this and the the conversations where
we where I figured out how where we were
kind of miscommunicating where I was an
understanding wherever the people were
coming from we're really enlightening
for me and I actually I still think
about Patrice all the time because when
I go out and give when I go out and give
seminars to machine learning crowds I I
kind of harken back to the way that I
first kind of crystallized how to
explain why what I was doing or thinking
way I was think about was a little bit
different and then at the same time I
really sort of shifted my career a lot
in the last six or seven years to try to
bring machine learning into economics
and so I feel like there's actually this
really exciting marrying
of two disciplines both its
transformative economics but also there
there actually there were a few things
that we did know along the way that
we're useful and and can also be
embedded and machine learning now
there's some of you here to which this
is like not new because one of the few
places that really has a great
concentration of people bringing
together a machine learning and causal
inference as Microsoft and we have it
among some of the economists from like
Greg Lewis in in New England and Matt
tatty work that he did while he was here
on project Alice of course Emre is here
and we've had people come through likely
Amba to who's someone that we thought a
lot about counterfactual reasoning an ad
Center with and so on so this um and so
and of course a lot of the work in the
New York lab on contextual bandits also
is is very solidly in the in the causal
inference framework so it's I'm when I
when I generalize about machine learning
and if I slip anywhere along the way
just let me make sure like to start with
I'm carving out that elite brilliant
group of exceptions that is that is sort
of bringing these things together and
when I'm generalizing I'm thinking more
about like the broad the broad world of
sort of image recognition with neural
nets so just to not offend anyone I
realized that not everybody doing
machine learning is only doing that okay
so with all of that a precursor I want
to talk about a line of research that
I'm today I'm gonna talk about a line of
research I've been working on with David
Bly human if you know as computer
scientist at Columbia to that that whose
goal is really to bring together
econometrics models with with Bayesian
probabilistic models to do
counterfactual inference before I dive
into that I'll mention that and I've a
lot of them I have two strands of this
machine learning and causal inference
literature the most of my presentations
the machine learning audiences have
focused on the other strand which is
more about estimating heterogeneous
treatment effects building things into
a/b testing platform personalized policy
evaluation and recently I've been
thinking about contextual bandits as
well so that is one I think in a very
easy place where machine learning and
cut and causal and friends come together
because personalized prediction and
sighs treatment effects are very close
now if you don't if you're not smart you
can get wildly wrong answers when you
make that leap but if you're a little
bit clever and you incorporate some
basic insights then you can modify the
techniques pretty not too hard and and
and get personalized treatment effects
and so on
so that is one line and I'm very excited
about that line and of course Emory and
others here are part of that broader
literature as well as other folks in New
York this second line is fitting in with
a different branch of economics which we
would call structural modeling and
structural this branch more naturally
connects with people who build
probabilistic models because we're
writing down generative models of how
the world works and I would say the
difference between the economists and
the the non economists Bayesian would be
that the economists are going to think a
little take a little bit more seriously
the idea that we're estimating like
preferences we're estimating a consumers
preferences and therefore we're really
getting something fundamental or
structural about a person or about a
firm so that we can take them to new
environments but the applicate we have
more complicated applications of that
Auctions is one that I've spent a lot of
time on where I assume that bidders are
maximizing profits and they're playing
equilibria those are more I was a
stronger assumption stronger behavioral
assumptions if you make those
assumptions you can say things the one
I'm gonna talk about today all I'm gonna
I'm gonna be assuming that consumers
choose what's best for them
so it's a fairly weak kind of behavioral
assumption but nonetheless those
assumptions can be used to make to do
counterfactual inferences so just that's
how this all kind of fits in so I'm
going to be fitting into a strand of the
economics literature that you guys might
not see as much unless you've been
listening to Matt Teddy and Greg Lewis
ok so just to say the the the class of
datasets that we're working with here
are we call an economics panel or
longitudinal data sets where we're
seeing a bunch of units over time and so
example data sets of course one of the
things that inspired this work was work
I was doing on News using Microsoft data
you might have a set of users and see
the the news articles they viewed or the
website
they viewed one of the data sets I'm
going to look at today is GPS data so
I've got device ID for millions of
people and then I have a sequence of
time-stamped latitudes and longitudes
that's another that's the first data set
I'll talk about today another data set
that I'm starting to work with would be
consumer credit card transactions where
you where you see again the consumer ID
and the timestamp and the location and
the amount of the charge or I'm in out
another day said I'll look at today is
shopping data so you see the consumer ID
and what they bought and so the kinds of
kind of counterfactual questions that we
might think about are in the news
setting we might say well how will users
change their consumption of news if for
example Google News shuts down and and
Marcus Moebius who's at MSR New England
and I wrote a paper about that where
Google News shut down in Spain and so we
tried to make predictions about what
they were in this case what they would
have done if Google News hadn't shut
down and though that's a counterfactual
though we might actually have an actual
event and then we can we can verify our
results how do physical movements of
consumers change if say they say lose a
job or the one I'm gonna focus on is
what happens if a store opens and closes
how is that consumer going to change
their shopping patterns and so one thing
I want to work on the future is like the
retail apocalypse so we see some of
these chain stores closing and what is
that do to consumer shopping behavior
you know various other things what
products make good loss leaders like
what what if I want to if a supermarket
is going to put something on sale what
would be good products to put on sale to
attract people into the store and to
attract particular types of people into
the store so the common features are
that we have some structured data about
the objects and some some cases will
have prices but I'm generally going to
be thinking about things where I don't
have a lot of structured data about the
objects the consumers consume maybe a
wide variety of products and I want to
understand their choices so this is sort
of you know roughly the related to the
recommendation system problem which you
guys have all studied a lot one approach
to that is a matrix factorization
approach so we can think about a matrix
of movies and users and we're going to
try to come up
with a say of factor structure we can
represent this matrix as a as a there's
D dimensional latent user preferences
for characteristics of movies and
there's a d-dimensional latent vector
which describes the characteristics of
the movies and I can predict the users
preference for the movies by multiplying
those two matrices together and broadly
this is answering the question what
types of things the users like and of
course I know and I'm very well aware
that there are lots of extensions and
generalizations of this but just
high-level this kind of simple matrix
factorization can can predict what kinds
of things they like of course if you
think about from the perspective of
Amazon this is a company like that doing
this type of analysis can be very simple
you can take the whole year's worth of
amazon purchases and sort of just you
know boil it down to a matrix you're
gonna be losing a lot of information
though when you boil that down because
you might be throwing away information
about well what did the consumer buy
together like maybe they bought you know
you know hot dogs and hot dog buns
together and I'll come back to that and
that says something that's more no
that's more interesting that they bought
them together than if they bought them
at different times during the year maybe
the product was on sale when they bought
that product and so the reason they
bought that product is because it was on
sale maybe the reason that they didn't
buy a product was because I never showed
it to them my existing recommendation
system just didn't recommend this type
of product to this consumer so while
this this this approach is very helpful
it doesn't if you if you start from here
you of course it's um completely
impossible to answer questions about
what would happen if I change prices
because you're not really modeling why
they bought things to start with the
economics and marketing literature's and
there's there's basically part of
marketing that basically is economics we
like computer science we tend to invade
and adjacent disciplines and take them
over so that's one of the subjects of
our invasion so we would typically build
a functional form model of the user
utility and estimate preferences based
on the user choice behavior but this
literature which like Daniel dan
McFadden won a Nobel Prize for his work
on Nitin his work on this in 1971 and -
so this is a very very old literature
there he was modeling the extension of
the bark so he was modeling consumers
transportation choices but same kind of
setting one product at the time like
different brands of yogurt we typically
have very simple models like we have a
single product specific latent variable
which we might think of as product
quality typically in the old days we
didn't have micro consumer data and so
what we worried about was that that
might be correlated with price so when
you might worry that if we just had like
a single data set with with constant
prices and the data set then we don't
know if people are but are not buying
this product because it has a high price
or if it's because it has low quality
and we might expect generally the higher
quality products have higher prices so
if we compare across products say here's
a low price product and here's a high
price product that's not going to tell
us anything about what would happen if a
single product changed its price so
people were very worried about this
latent variable of product quality but
it was correlated with price and so they
spent a lot of time trying to think
about things that would shock prices
like cost shocks and so on that would
move prices as a natural experiment and
using that to try to learn about the
effects of price but usually from
aggregate data now as we went along we
got more of this shot like your scanner
data where we would see the same
consumers over time and we would see the
prices at individual consumers visited
saw when they visited the store and so
then it's actually much easier to try to
understand the causal effect of price
because you know I might see two
essentially identical consumer as one
comes in on Tuesday one comes in on
Wednesday the price goes down on
Wednesday and and they buy on Wednesday
and not on Tuesday so roughly it's not
completely exhaust variation but if you
control for enough stuff the idea is
that you know you can think of whether
you came in on Tuesday or Wednesday
before the price change or after as as
as simple as good as random and so that
type of price variation can then be used
to understand the effect of price in a
way that's much harder to do in
aggregate data and then what this
literature did is it actually stuck with
this one product at a time thing but it
actually went off in a whole bunch of
other directions which actually relate
now to the inverse reinforcement
learning literature
they would basically assume Oh suppose
this consumer is solving a dynamic
programming problem and they're
stockpiling laundry detergent so you
know one of my PhD students like wrote
their whole thesis on you know stock
pipe
well what one was stockpiling laundry
detergent another was like
experimentation versus habit formation
and laundry detergent so we're modeling
all these consumers solving dynamic
programming problems were estimating the
value function and inferring their
dynamic preferences from that so that
literature we went into a very I would
say structural direction this was sort
of controversial because people didn't
like all the assumptions and like why is
it habit formation here and it's
stockpiling there and why are you
stockpiling in this way and not in that
way and so it was it's controversial
because of all the assumptions but
that's sort of the direction the
literature went in which is a very
different direction than we think about
like these big recommendation system
models which were looking at lots of
products one product at a time misses
many aspects of consumer choice for
example actually if you ask like safe
I'm sorry an unnamed grocery store gave
me this data actually back in the early
2000s and the the grocery store actually
the problem they came to was they said I
want to understand how to segment my
consumers and I want to understand how
to give them coupons and how to do these
price emotions and discounts but they
were thinking about like store to store
competition they were thinking man I
want to get the consumers into the store
and see and they would buy other things
so those types of questions are really
not answered by just studying yogurt and
you're studying yogurt you can
understand the effect of coupons or
something or TV ads but it's hard to
understand the things that are
interesting to a store and you know
organizing the store and so on and then
in the in the online space there's sort
of the online version of shelf space so
what should I show consumers what what
should I recommend to them on the page
what kinds of discounts would get what
if I email them a discount offer what's
gonna get them to come to my website but
if they come to my website they're gonna
buy other things and so like there's
some of my colleagues did some work at
eBay where they sort of found that you
know if you or when a base would have
made changes that made it cheaper for
sellers to listings on eBay in fact
those those sellers bought stuff when
they came to eBay and so just getting
the sellers to come to eBay increase
their
revenue because the sellers bought stuff
while they were on the store so the
spillover effect was very big and and
Maxima traits will remember back in the
day eBay you said kind of put a lot of
spam ads on bing and part of that is
because if you could just get that
consumer to click and come to eBay even
if the ad had nothing to do with the
query maybe they'd buy something so this
idea of getting people into the store
matters for that so what we're gonna do
in this line of research is we're gonna
try to bring in matrix factorization and
embedding tech methods from CS and we're
gonna use a Bayesian approach for it
doesn't have to be Bayesian but we we
liked it for a variety of reasons we get
flexibility and incorporating the
structure we can also represent well the
uncertainty that for some consumers we
don't really know very much and for
other consumers we know more and we can
ensure using priors that the consumers
work we don't know very much we can
learn using hierarchical priors and so
there's basically two we're gonna pay
we're gonna estimator an economic style
structural model using computational
techniques from machine learning and
we're gonna be paying particular
attention to identification so
identification is the economics jargon
for you know can you really learn
something from this like is there
actually variation in prices it helps
you learn that and also we're gonna
we're gonna tune our models along
counterfactuals so we're gonna try to
select models that do well on
counterfactuals rather than models that
do well in straight prediction so I'll
try to flesh that out I would say
generally though that is a theme that I
think can be taken away to the machine
learning people maybe in especially you
know the canonical machine learning we
often just think okay we want to predict
well we're gonna look at goodness-of-fit
machine means quart of air long
likelihood but if what you're actually
going to do is is think about changing a
price then instead of tuning the model
for goodness of fit I should hold out
some price changes and see how well I do
with these kinds of counterfactual
exercises and so those types of getting
the right optimization the right
objective function can really make a
difference so there's two ways you can
use this we can use it the way we do in
economics normally but if I think about
it a large scale it can also be a
pre-processing step so we might be able
to take a there gonna be some scaling
issues with this so I might be able to
learn some things about the latent
variable structure from a model like
this and then embed it in
in a model that's maybe simpler to
compute and so that's also something I
would think and it could be useful in
tech firms as well okay so basically
we're going to apply these large field
18 variable approaches with multiple
observed product characteristics and
we're gonna consider lots of products at
once and as we go along I'm going to
talk about distinguishing correlation
from complementarity testing assumptions
and so on let me actually jump into the
first paper now so the first paper this
came out in the papers and proceedings
in May of the American Economic
Association and so this paper I'm
actually going in reverse order
chronologically this is the last paper
we wrote in the last paper we began but
it's the simplest in some ways so I'm
going to start there and then get more
complicated so here from the the
counterfactual questions are questions
like where should a restaurant be
located what's the best type of
restaurant for a location who are a
restaurants competitors and how far will
a consumer travel to a restaurant they
like and I would say these are examples
of sort of product design location and
quality questions and there's a there's
lots of analogues to these questions
that firms would make and so if you were
thinking about you know surface how many
how many SKUs should there be in surface
or how many products should how many
versions of sequel should we offer or
questions like that they would sort of
fit into this type of a framework as
well so we're gonna start we because we
have got computer science colleagues
I've got nice little acronyms for all of
my my models so this is we call this the
travel time factorization model of user
choice and so but in the economics
framework we start by writing down a
utility that's just kind of the
convention we have so it's gonna map
into a probabilistic model like one for
one but we usually just start by writing
down utility so we say the users utility
has written has these components there's
a popularity component for item I for
restaurant I then there's the consumer
preferences which are product of latent
factors so this user you has a vector of
latent preferences and a restaurant I is
going to have a vector of latent factors
then this is the part that gets a little
more I would say structural although
it's I mean I don't want to glorify it
too much it's just but
we're doing sort of tuning on the model
here we're gonna say that you you're
gonna care about the distance between
user you and item I so this this
covariate varies if the user item level
and we're gonna put it in a log format
because there's sort of some concavity
we think with distance and then we're
going to factorize the coefficients so
we're going to say that there's a user
item specific preference for distance
but that's gonna be represented in
latent factors so what that's gonna
allow us to say is that I'm not willing
to travel very far for coffee but I am
willing to travel for good food so if
you think about it like so we're going
to find later is that people are willing
to travel farther in the Bay Area for
like Asian restaurants but they don't
travel for coffee but of course there's
lots of restaurants so I I can't
possibly learn my user items specific
preference but it at that level so am i
factorizing it I can figure out there
are types of restaurants that users are
willing to drive to and types of they're
not then there's a time varying effect
which could capture that maybe some
restaurants are good when it rains and
some restaurants are good when it
doesn't rain or different times of year
or with students and then we have noise
and we also and then we're gonna have
covariance which effect we have a
hierarchical Bayesian models they're
gonna affect the mean of the prior of
these different things so we have say
160 restaurant types we can't learn each
users preference for 160 things because
the users only go to like 12 restaurants
but I can I can learn that the latent
vector for Japanese restaurants is
similar to that for Chinese restaurants
and that's gonna go into the
hierarchical prior on the Alfa's so this
is the way we write it in economics and
it turns out that it's fairly
straightforward to show that if the if
the consumer is just choosing the
maximum of those if you assume that the
consumer choose the maximum of those
then the probability that user you and
time t chooses item I is this multi this
multinomial logit format so yep don't
you need an assumption of the noisiest
distribution yes exactly the error needs
to be a loggia error it needs to be
extreme value type one extreme value
error and so if it's a type one extreme
value error then we get this functional
form and so I'm and
of course in machine learning you would
have just said it started and say I'm
gonna do I'm gonna write down a
multinomial logit probabilistic model in
economics we just say well it's
convenient to know that if a consumer is
maximizing utility and their utility
looks like this then the parameters you
learn from doing this estimation are
actually the parameters of their utility
function now you say well why do I care
well if you're going to predict in the
same environment you don't care right if
the environments stable then you don't
need to care why the consumer did what
they did all you need to know is what
they did but if I change the the
distance or if I make a particular
restaurant unavailable or if I you know
if something if I put a different
restaurant in the same location things
like that then I then I need to think
about why the consumer like what they
did in order to infer their choices and
so the way that we've typically done
this in economics there's a few people
who do this with distance usually this
is done with price and in the second two
papers I'm we're gonna focus on price
but here it's distance that we're
learning the effective okay so so then
this isn't this is like part of what Dan
McFadden got the Nobel Prize for and I
mean who might seen this is like not
terribly deep this was also the early
1970s he then developed a series of
extensions of these models and looked at
their properties as well one is called
the nested logit which I'll come back to
later which he also popularized okay and
so then in the in this paper this is
written to economists so I'm gonna
compare for the economists perspective
to a simple multinomial logit comparison
which is what the economists would
normally have done is they would not
have this factorization and they
wouldn't have these this these
complicated factors instead they would
just have like a constant price effect
or if they do use them much more
sophisticated framework there might be
you might have only five choices and
then there would be a user but not item
just a user specific coefficient on
price that we call we call it a random
coefficients model so this model is
different from the traditional economic
models and listen in that we have a lot
more items and we're factorizing them
yep price effect going into the customer
preferences component in this particular
model yeah
the restaurants because we don't have
price variation you this is an
identification problem I can't tell them
I can't really tell why you like a
restaurant if the restaurant never
changes its price now what I can learn
is I actually have like the the Yelp
kind of price categories in there and I
treat that as an observable
characteristic so I can sort of learn
those characteristics but I wouldn't
like completely hang my hat on that in
the sense that if Chinese restaurants
are always in the three dollar sign and
Mexican are always in the two dollar
sign I can't really tell the difference
between is this because it's Chinese or
because it's expensive I can't tell that
so I so we don't put a lot we don't put
a we would say in economics we don't put
a structural or interpretation or we
don't put a causal interpretation on it
because we don't have variation in it
and there's a little bit of that problem
with the distance as well but because I
have this same variable I can measure
across different restaurants I feel more
comfortable although I would say that
the criticism from the economists would
be how do you really know that you're
not willing to travel the Chinese and
you just don't like Chinese and so
there's a bit of a problem that's not
it's not perfectly it's not it's not the
best application of a causal estimate
okay so the data comes from safe graph
which is a company that aggregates
locational information from consumers
who've opted into sharing their location
through mobile applications so you
accept when you install the mobile
application to have your data shared
this is aggregated anonymously and then
securely researchers are able to do
research on that on that data in in with
some aggregations and anonymization
implicit there we're gonna study January
through October 2017 in the Bay Area and
so part of the reason we picked lunch
restaurants is that if you think about
location data it's sort of hard to tell
exactly what a consumers doing by where
they are but if I see you at a
restaurant at lunch time I kind of know
what you're doing so one of the you know
another example would be like if I see
you at a park or if I see you in a movie
theater if I see you at a grocery store
so there's some things that are very
well revealed by location data and and
restaurants is one of them yeah what
does it do well first of all it never
knows any PII for the canoe
so it's it's always it's it's just
linked by device ID and then there's
sort of geographic fuzziness around it -
yes but I mean so this is this data is
not it's not released to the public so
we also are signing non-disclosure
agreements and the data is protected
just like data you know inside of tech
companies is protected so yeah it's not
anonymized to the extent that I would
post it on the web so I mean maybe that
would be okay but it hasn't
they haven't intended it to be done that
way yeah so so then what we do is we
construct the typical morning location
of the consumer design is the most
commonplace to consumers found between
9:00 and 11:15 a.m. we throw out a lot
of people they don't have consistent
warning locations so we actually throw
out quite a lot of people as we narrow
down to people for whom we can do this
study well so we've just taken like a
selected sample of people that we can
understand their behavior very well they
have to have most of their morning pings
in their morning location this paper
we're just doing like the west side of
the bay kind of down through the down
through the Silicon Valley to San Jose
we're gonna call a lunch restaurant
visit is if we observed at least two
pings more than three minutes apart
between 11:30 and 1:30 and this also
really kills us because a lot of we
don't have a ton of pings and so a lot
of people ping once but they could have
just been walking by so with more work
we could try to do more to get more
pings back in but we just stuck with
this and then the restaurants are
identified using data that Yelp provided
us that uses geo coordinates star
ratings price range as well as the
restaurant opening and closing times so
in our in our data we have four per user
we have about 12 visits per user and
again this is a not this is a selected
sample of users that had plenty of
visits they visited seven distinct
restaurants so just because I see the
user I don't exactly know where they're
gonna go next
they each restaurant is in multiple Yelp
category so they actually visited more
than seven distinct categories they went
on average distance of three miles
restaurants actually traveling a little
further than I thought they would and so
on from the restaurant perspective the
restaurants this is a data scan of
sparse when we could do once we narrow
down to a small user base then we're not
going to have a lot of visits per
restaurant so our restaurants only get
about fourteen visits per restaurant and
so on okay so then the estimation we do
Bayesian estimation with a hierarchical
prior there's a Gaussian prior over the
latent characteristics which are shifted
by the observed covariates like the
ratings and the price categories and the
restaurant types and then we estimate
the coefficients on on on those
characteristics these matrices H we use
mean-field variational inference to
approximate the posterior we're using
independent gaussians and we find the
parameters that minimize the distance
it's yet to be seen how much people are
going to hate this in economics because
we have typically used money mark Markov
chain Monte Carlo in economics and
people have felt strongly about like
this type of approximation has not been
sort of I would say accepted yet I'm
testing the waters by putting it out
there and so we will see how much people
complain about it but I think my
response to that is historically
economists thought about it is we were
gonna write down a model we were gonna
say God the God of economics gave us the
model we were gonna get all the
functional forms and we were gonna get
it sort of perfectly right which is and
then we're gonna do sort of theoretical
the theory is gonna tell us and
statistical theory will tell us if it's
right and we'll get confidence intervals
and standard errors well the machine
learning perspective is a little more
we're gonna hold out test data and see
if it works now that does that's not as
helpful for counterfactual inference but
so what we're gonna try to do is find
datasets that have lots and lots of
experiments in them or think natural
experiments so that we can hold out test
data of experiments and see if it works
rather and then that will hopefully
convince the people who are used to
having theorems that say that they're
getting the right answer because if
you're approximating the posterior with
independent gaussians obviously you're
not getting the right answer so I can't
prove a theorem that says that I am but
but it it's it works well enough okay so
in terms of model fit so again you guys
probably are less interested in this
this really kind of stupid multinomial
benchmark stupid in the sense of it
doesn't have a lot of parameters and
heterogeneity this is again kind of more
of a benchmark ups against the classic
economics approach so I'll just kind of
show you our model and the test sample
we get our precision at one is about
twenty percent our precision at five is
thirty five percent and at ten is forty
two percent so we're doing a reasonably
good reasonably good job of of
predicting what users are choosing we
break out our goodness of fit in a
variety of ways to show basically how
this works with user deciles so here's
an example on the test set the precision
at one is going to be much higher for
the for the tenth decile of user rest
restaurant consumption so the users who
use a lot were much better and so the
model is able to adapt to the more
frequent users and learn their
preferences better and same with
restaurants restaurants that are more
popular we're able to also predict those
better and so on this picture we're
looking at how we do in terms of fitting
the how distance relates to the visit
probability so the actual relationship
is here in red so this is the the visit
probability is a function of the users
distance from the restaurant and we see
that actually in this aggregate way both
the simple multinomial logit and the
personalised TTFN multinomial logit both
fit the shape pretty well and so
actually one insight is that and
actually we're talking about this
earlier with with some colleagues here
is that whether you want a complicated
machine learning model or a complicated
personalised model depends on the
question you're asking and if you just
want to ask a simple question like how
does distance from users on average
relate to probability then actually a
simple model can do that on average and
it's a little less bumpy than my my
complicated model but if you want to ask
how will this user respond then of
course you need a more personalized
models so in some sense if we were
tuning for just this kind of aggregate
predict
we should throw away all the latent
variables and choose a very simple model
but if I'm tuning for personalization
then I should use a more complex model
and I done that because actually a lot
of economic questions actually are a
little bit more aggregate I might be
raising a price for a segment of
consumers or making an offer for a group
of consumers and then all the pertinent
necessarily want full personalization
okay then let me now show you just a few
of the results so first of all we
compute elasticity so elasticity is how
a percentage change in X leads to a
percentage change in Y so now we're
looking at how does the percentage
change and distance lead to a percentage
change and visit probability and so
these elasticity's they're negative
because if something's further away
you're less likely to visit and we can
see here just kind of ranking Mexican
you're very sensitive to distance while
say Chinese and Japanese you're less
sensitive to distance and the you're
more sensitive we don't actually have a
lot of price range threes and fours at
lunch so mostly the 1 versus 2 is where
we have data and so you're less willing
to travel for cheap restaurants and
you're less willing to travel for low
rated restaurants so how would you
actually distinguish these yes so
basically what's the way that we would
tease these apart would be that there's
some Chinese restaurants that are in 1
versus 2 but as I mentioned earlier we
don't have experimental variation in
this stuff so I wouldn't interpret these
completely I wouldn't go out and make
business decisions based on these
results but I would say that they're
sort of descriptive but they they and
and these are these are the where these
are getting estimated as terms of the
loadings on these variables and the
hierarchical prior yep so the previous
plots I interpreted those as just you've
set up this ranking problem better
you're going to rank whether utility is
predicted by your model yep and then
check the position at one position but
but I was ensuring that the model stated
was actually identifiable that you could
pin down the parameters of that model to
within epsilon of the ground truth
parameter
the users we're actually behaving
according to that model so I don't know
what to make of these numbers like it
could well be that I could come up with
two alternative explanations that just
my optimization happen to pick one of
those today yes so I would say here the
identification is less clean and so III
as I said I'm not I don't you you could
find another way to fit that would load
up more on some of these factors and not
on others I'm going to show you in a
minute the way that we tried to test it
with restaurants opening and closing but
this data set was too small so we didn't
have sufficient power so now I'm going
to move next to the supermarket data
where I have like thousands of price
changes and they're it's it's it's
cleaner to sort of pick that out so I
think that the the thing on the distance
though is in some sense I'm seeing I'm
seeing I'm kind of generalizing a little
bit there there are some some
extrapolation assumptions basically that
like I'm assuming that these these you
if I seen users who have different
choice sets then I can infer something
about distance and also the fact that
I'm seeing this user go to lots of
different restaurants but I am relying
at some level on functional form
assumptions to tease out how to
attribute things to distance versus
Chinese versus versus price so I'm
learning that I'm partly by looking
across users yeah for the highest
quintile that users I mean that seems
like yeah I that's it's a little weird I
don't know about that one with the price
range we don't have any data but here
that I would I again this could this
could be a cautionary tale that you
shouldn't interpret that structurally
okay so we also look at differences
across cities and we see that there are
some cities where people are willing to
travel far and these tend to be the ones
where things are farther apart well
they're less willing to travel in some
of the denser cities then we we look at
how the model predictions for the
effects of at restaurant openings and
closings controlling for other changes
so we look at like if a restaurant
closed what is the impact on the typical
Trott within 2 miles 2 to 4 miles 4 to 6
miles and so on and so this this model
basically tells us how the impact of the
restaurant opening and closing is
distributed so another problem with this
application as it is now and so I'm just
I'm I'm like by the way you've probably
figured out by now like I don't like go
to town defending my papers so I'm sort
of telling you the strengths and
weaknesses but so we're we're trying to
extend this in a variety of ways the
thing that actually varies in the data
is we do see restaurants opening and
closing
but each restaurant there's so many
restaurants that each restaurant has
only like this very tiny impact on the
restaurants around it and so you need a
lot of data to actually pin this down so
in particular here these are the actual
impacts from the restaurants we have
several hundred held out restaurants
openings and closings in the data but we
see that the the standard deviations are
really big for the actuals and so you're
not really going to be able to tell that
your model has performed well by how
well it fits these actuals so this was
sort of a proof of concept paper and so
what now we get a sense of the power
calculation we need to like do many more
cities and a longer time period in order
to get these error bars down to be a
meaningful level where we could say like
one model is better than another model
at doing those counterfactuals yep what
an efference point to which these
distances are defined during lunchtime
my work location would matter more then
yes so I'm using your morning location
so I only pick users are in the same
place every morning and I use their
morning location yep thank you to go
back a couple slides to the coefficients
and the standard errors so just looking
at this one thing that I jumped out at
me is these coefficients are very
similar across cities and the standard
errors are all very small and what that
suggests to me is there's a lot of
shrinkage of individual effects being
shrunk to a common effect that's going
on here and I'm wondering if you can say
something about exactly what that
parameter is a Bayesian model and then
how well identified it is and if perhaps
yes so actually these point these these
are not parameters these we didn't
actually put in city in the model this
is just us aggregating the data after
the fact but it's but it is suggesting
that we are that we
maybe don't have enough you know we
don't have enough data or it could just
suggest that people are kind of similar
and how far they're willing to drive yes
there is not a palo alto term of the
model you're learning and overall
category of elasticity and that varies
across types of people and there's
shrinkage that perhaps is shrinking
those elasticity's across different
types of people to a common mean exactly
a lot of shrinkage is being applied then
you're ending up with exactly and so I
mean I think one of the one of my
takeaways from say that this project is
that you know you you actually do need
quite a bit of data you know so seeing
people go to 12 restaurants maybe you
know you you could you need more data
than that because the priors can still
matter and also I need you know having
hundreds of experiments isn't that
helpful if those experiments are really
noisy so I need thousands and thousands
of experiments not hundreds in order to
pin things down because we're really
varying in the model is that people's
choice sets are changing but but that's
there's not that much of there's not
enormous amount of that going on here in
this in the urn in this prototype yeah
this is saying of some one thing but
like on the previous slide you
attributed like the reversal of the
direction to the small sample size but
the coefficients were still
statistically different from each other
yeah no no I don't have to distribute
that to the small sample size I would
attribute that to that we don't have
excitedness variation and those things
so it could be it could be proxying for
something else so I don't think of those
as I don't think of those isn't like
causal effects if I really wanted to
know the effect of those price things
and I would want to run an experiment
where the same restaurant changed its
price but I don't have that so expensive
restaurants are better in some other way
so yes the denominator of the
multinomial model are you thinking of
the entire universe of items or are you
thinking of somehow modeling what are
the items the user might have been
exposed to so in practice we cut it a
bit but we look and like within 12 miles
so each users got hundreds of choices so
in in like in an online setting you
might imagine modeling that exposure and
that's actually my original project this
this whole thing was supposed to be for
like using Internet Explorer to look at
people's news behavior but we
so haven't gotten to that project yet
because we're building up like one thing
at the time actually think now we're
ready to do that and actually our code
can accommodate that
but there's then there's there's more
modeling decisions to make about exactly
how you think about what the users are
exposed to and what order they're in and
so on yeah there are a couple location
papers out there that say another reason
that people pick places to go is because
their friends are chosen the place and
they just want to go along with their
friends
so does your original location data let
you model an effect I would love to do
that this this type of location data I'm
getting people is pinging a couple of
times a day and so you just really can't
do like you are at the same place as
this other person when I first got heard
about the data I was like there's gonna
be all these cool things I'm gonna see
this person is here with this other
person and I'm gonna do look at their
networks and yeah that's not it's not
really good at that it's sort of good at
like counting things that where you go
and you stay clear for a long time but I
can't it's just very noisy if I think of
like I would like to ideally I mean you
can forget about privacy of course from
a research perspective it would be nice
if I could see everybody where they are
continuously all day long that this data
is very very far from that you know
Google has that data you know from the
from their phones but I don't and that's
not enough to get me to go work at
Google and I don't think anybody has
published on that data because I think
if people thought a little bit about it
you know that might be making a little
nervous okay so alright so then one of
the things we we look at is we compare
we like to show you the picture but it's
a little bit noisy how we do relative to
the actuals let's see let me just show a
few pictures what some of the types of
things you can do or you can say if I
want to think about a restaurant
category we're in what parts are user
preferences such that they relatively
more like a category so let me come down
to Vietnamese so Vietnamese is very
strong south of Santa in the south south
San Jose which is sort of corresponds to
where there's pot that population we can
also ask
that's where Vietnamese is
relatively popular relative to other
places that Vietnamese is like we can
also ask if I picked a location what
would be the best category for that
location so if I counterfactually took
this restaurant away and put in another
restaurant of a different category what
would be the choice and we make that
choice among relatively similar things
and so we can see here like this is
where salad is good and this is where
Burgers is good if I look only among
Asian restaurants Vietnamese is great
here you know further up the peninsula
people are more partial to Chinese and
then there's like a Japanese preference
section in here so this type of model
could be used in one reason that the
safe graph and Yelp were kind of
interested in this was that this is
actually a use case for their data that
people are trying to figure out where to
locate stores and so if you understood
people's preferences you can think about
this counterfactual you can understand
better you know who are your competitors
and and what would you do
so that's so that so basically just to
sum up this paper the first paper here
it's the its I would say the least
tight of the papers in terms of the
causal identification of saying like
have I really told you that that of I'm
sure that I've disentangle distance from
other things but on the other hand we do
have we do see users making choices in
users and we see restaurants opening and
closing so I say have some confidence
and I'm learning and then I'm I'm trying
to pose here whether or not I've
completely estimated the parameters
correctly also illustrating the kinds of
counterfactuals
that you would like to do assuming that
you did have those parameters so the
reason to get these structural
parameters whether or not you think I've
done it perfectly is to do these kinds
of counterfactuals and so the research
agenda is then to find datasets where
you can learn them as well as build
better models to answer these kinds of
questions yep in this best restaurant
category to try to understand how the
model is being interpreted is it the
case that you want to place a restaurant
in the location where the people like
that category but there are no other
things of that category around so my
place at B Tammy's restaurant in a place
where there are no Vietnamese
restaurants but people are willing to
travel distance for that or I'm placing
it around other things that was similar
type so for example you place a coffee
shop next to a Starbucks because
everybody learns that you felt
some of their their actual market that
way which oh so I guess like in the
absence of this model then you would
have to reason about all of those things
what we actually do is we just simulate
and because this is where you really get
the power of the economic model I mean
it's a very simple economic model the
power of optimization we're assuming we
understand consumers preferences and
we're assuming that each consumer solves
an optimization problem that means if I
change the choice set I can just have
each consumer reoptimize so we're
literally running a simulation where we
we re optimize for the for each consumer
and we come up counterfactually with
what they would have chosen then I could
post-process that and try to explain why
like I could I could go back and say
well why is it salad here and I could
look at well it's is it salad here
because there's actually not a lot of
salad places there and there's an
unserved demand for salad or is it that
salads here because the people here have
really strong preferences for salad and
you could try to go back and sort of
post process and explain why you got
this answer but this is just coming
literally from simulating and assuming
you have the user preferences correct
for instance you won't know until you
open a restaurant but it's very well so
I think you would yes and so that that
the weakness of this is that I said
earlier I don't give these things
complete causal interpretations and now
I just did a counterfactual where I did
give them causal interpretations so you
know take it with a grain of salt but I
think what you would think about the
positioning is you would say I'm in a
position a restaurant and I'm gonna hire
a good chef and I know that I need to be
in this category in order to succeed and
you could roughly say like if there's
unobservable around the location you
would need okay I need to be comparable
to the things that are in the category
so if Chinese is proxying for a quiet
location to have a business meeting then
you would want to make your Chinese
restaurant kind of like other Chinese
restaurants and if you made your Chinese
restaurant different from other Chinese
restaurants and it wasn't a great place
to go with your colleagues for lunch
then you might fail so so we haven't we
haven't fully uncovered the production
function for the restaurant
there's omitted variables and so that's
the part that's not is completely clean
actually you guys this is the meet me
the me
move on to the other papers if you don't
mind unless like does somebody have
something like super pressing okay so
because I think the next papers actually
get more and more interesting and yeah
okay so let me now go to shopping data
so here we have a data set that was
constructed by some other people I
actually originally procured the data
but then they wrote this really nice
paper with it where they found a single
isolated grocery store and they they
cleaned up the data for all loyalty club
shoppers at that single isolated store
over an 18-month period and they went
through and actually did a bunch of
coding to figure out out of stock data
and approximately the hourly level so
they could figure out if a product went
out of stock and we also in this store
all the prices changed on Tuesday night
so so in the nice thing about Tuesday
night and I think this is probably why
they picked it is the Tuesday and
Wednesday are very similar shopping days
they're kind of indistinguishable in
terms of what people buy Friday is
different Monday is different you know
nighttime is different than daytime even
for the same consumer but roughly
Tuesday and Wednesday or very similar
days in terms of how people shop and
then we have the product hierarchy for
this and so in the first paper we're
gonna use the observed product hierarchy
so I know the UPC and all these
different categorizations of the product
in the second paper on the same data set
I'm going to throw this away and I'm
gonna try to infer those things from
from the choice behavior so we look at
users who had at least 20 shopping trips
on Tuesday or Wednesday with more than
10 items per trip we started with a top
2/3 235 categories so a category will be
like tomatoes or toilet paper or yogurt
we throw out things where that people
basically only bought one product we
also there's some things like frozen
dinners where all of the products and
the category have prices that move
together so like all the frozen dinners
are expensive one week and they're cheap
the next week so we threw those out so
we only kept categories where people
bought different products from the
categories and where there was
independent variation in the price
because here now I'm gonna try to be a
little bit more rigorous on the causal
identification so I ended up with two
thousand consumers 123 categories 1263
items and 333,000 trip
and then we rather than do cross
validation because the models are
expensive to compute we just have a
single validation set yep
oh who changes them or what are they
thinking about when they change them
yeah that's that's a little complicated
it can be because manufacturer costs
change sometimes or it could be because
the store decided to do it ultimately
the the the chain often decides at the
chain level but something you might be
concerned about is like on some weeks
going from Tuesday to Wednesday might be
you might raise the price because like
Thursday Thanksgiving and so we're gonna
do some testing and actually throw out
products that have that kind of a
problem
so let me show you how we do the testing
for that so this is a price series this
is a typical price series for a single
UPC this is what a price series looks
like for the average prices for a
category mainstream white bread and so
we do see that they're sort of can be
like systematic trends in those prices
and and but there's also like once you
look across all the prices there's
actually a fair bit of price variation
like in most categories there's a price
change most weeks so we do actually have
a lot of you think of each price change
is kind of an experiment we have a lot
of experiments if we want to think about
the identifying assumption we're
basically going to say that the
counterfactual distribution of purchases
between Tuesday and Wednesday in weeks
with price changes can be constructed
from their behavior on the weeks without
price changes so what we're gonna do is
we're basically going to control we're
gonna have dummies for each week in
category so we're basically going to
learn how popular this product is this
week or this category is in this week
and then we're also gonna learn how went
different Tuesday and Wednesday are it
turns out they're not actually different
so that's not very important but we
control for that anyways and so
essentially what we're gonna assume is
that if I tell you the if I tell you the
how popular this week is and I tell you
whether it's a Tuesday or Wednesday I
can figure out what would have happened
if the price hadn't changed and so
that's that's a sort of a functional
form assumption but we think it's a
pretty good one in the sense that in
most products in most weeks Tuesday and
Wednesday are pretty much the same but
we're not going to just accept that
we're gonna do what we call up
boe tests now this is not a definitive
test it's just suggestive but it maybe
provide you some confidence and it also
gives you a way to kick things out so
like we use this to kick out stone
fruits for example turns out peaches are
really seasonal and so we you know
there's some things that kind of flunk
the test I'm going to do so what we're
gonna do is create fake price series
we're gonna ship the price series
forward or back in time and then we're
going to recalculate estimate the model
with fake price series and if there was
like an ongoing trend so the prices are
all going up and also demand is going up
at the same time then it would look like
there was a price change even in weeks
where there weren't a price change so
we're testing for a certain type of
problem in our model we do is we
estimate a simple multinomial logit
model we get the coefficients on price
and we want to look at the this is what
the price shifts look like and we want
to look at the distribution of the
p-values on the on the price coefficient
so in particular if if these prices were
just kind of random noise then the
p-values on the price coefficient should
be uniformly distributed there's there's
like there should be no effect of a
noisy price series and so we should see
a uniform distribution of p-values this
red is the actual distribution of
p-values with the actual price series
which is saying that most of the time we
we can think we think that there's a
significantly negative effect of the
price but with the fake price series
they look roughly uniform although not
perfectly uniform and we're arguing that
this sort of validates that are given
all the controls we've put in that the
prices that our assumption is is good
and there's not there some other kind of
time trend going on that we haven't
captured in our model but that we're not
testing every alternative we're just
testing alternatives about kind of
gradual shifts up or gradual shifts down
in the products popularity and so I'd
say this type of placebo test is been
used in economics but not usually it's
scale like we usually do like much
simpler versions of these and I would
say that there's some interesting ideas
of bringing these kinds of tests into
machine learning settings where we have
lots of experiments and that idea I
think we haven't we do it in a very
small like hand tuning way like if you
suppose there was a minimum wage changed
in 1980
for we Co would we think that the
minimum wage a change in 1983 if if the
model says that it would have that it
looks like there was an effect of a
change that didn't happen then we reject
our model but it feels like one change
in one year not lots of little changes
okay so if we say we throw out some
things and this works then let me go on
to our model
so our model like before we're gonna
have user utilities they're gonna have
factorized mean utilities now instead of
distance we have price and we're gonna
have factorize price coefficients and
again this model is going to say here
conditional on purchasing in a category
you have a multinomial logit form but
we're gonna add to our previous model is
the nested logit formulation which has
proved to be very popular and fits very
well in economics and so the problem is
that if I included the outside good
which is not buying anything in this
model the assumption that the errors are
iid is actually a really bad assumption
because some days you're gonna go to the
store and you really need paper towels
and so there's a correlated positive
shock for all the paper towels and not
buying a paper towel is is sort of a
separate option option and so then what
the nested logit basically assumes is
that first you choose buy a product or
not buy a product and then you choose
what to buy in the category and
technically it allows for correlation in
these errors across all the products
other than don't buy but a certain form
of correlation and the nice thing about
the nested logit from a computational
perspective is that you can actually
estimate it as is to sequential
multinomial logit s' so first and and so
it's more efficient to jointly estimate
them so like Stata and r will jointly
estimate them but because i have a very
complicated computational problem with
all my latent variables i'm gonna
estimate them sequentially which loses
something but it's it's it works so
first i'm going to model this
multinomial logit with all my latent
variables and then i'm gonna model the
choice of whether to buy anything at all
and there's gonna be a factorization of
the choice don't buy anything at all and
so it's a proof i mean it's like a page
of algebra you can show that that if you
put in the the utilities of for all of
the other items in the category that's
called the inclusive value using this
see functional form here inclusive value
is log of the sum of e to the use then
you will you will get the parameters of
the users utility function so I won't
show you that proof but that was part of
damage that ins work in the early 70s
was to do this
algebra which turned out to be very
convenient algebra so now I'm gonna do a
two-stage estimation first I'll do this
model get all the parameters figure out
the utilities then I take the utilities
construct the inclusive value of just
buying something and then I can do
another multinomial logit to choose
between buying something and buying
nothing and that allows for the
correlation and and it's very important
for fitting shopping data because most
consumers don't purchase so those zeros
are really important in the data and
this is something other people have
observed in machine learning as well the
zeros is really important for modeling
choice data okay we also use Bayesian
inference again and so I'm just going to
show you a few things so we compare this
actually was just a total pain in the
ass but we can we compared like a
zillion different common economic models
and we win otherwise I wouldn't be
showing you the slide so the the thing
that's kind of more interesting I would
say that we found is that we actually
focus on how we do in terms of
counterfactuals this is all weeks this
is weeks where one of the products in
the category is out of stock this is
weeks where one of the products has a
price change and I'm only looking at
your purchases of the product that had a
price change and this is this is
observations where another product in
the category had a price change and I'm
looking at purchases of the product that
didn't have the price change and so
these are all different counterfactuals
and so we actually end up finding
different model selection if we tuned
for say the price change counterfactual
rather than overall and so that says
that it's important to tune your model
for your goal and counterfactual will
put more of a weight on trying to
understand the role of the price changes
while otherwise you might put more role
work into the mean utility and so then
some of the things that we get out of
that we try to we we we did we use data
about categories but we didn't use about
subcategories which are called classes
or subclasses so within water there's
sparkling water and then there's like
flavored sparkling water is a subclass
that's just an example so what we find
is that our model does a better job at
understanding what's in the same class
so we find much higher cross price
elasticity so the impact of one products
price on another product within a class
than across classes so we understand
that sparkling waters are better
substitutes than flat water in sparkling
water in a way that the other models
can't okay so we what we is not quite
done yet so this is the first project we
started we started this like three years
ago but we have continued first we
needed to add we had to make all these
changes we had to add the nested logit
and this functional form and the way we
brought in the covariance and so on and
then we're right where now what we're
finishing is doing personalized pricing
and couponing strategies using this
relative to the economics literature we
spend a lot of time showing how pooling
information across you ters and items is
it really adds a lot of value so one of
the things if I just study lettuce you
don't buy lettuce that much and there's
not many price changes for lettuce but
if I understand that you're price
sensitive for lettuces since the similar
to your price sensitivity for tomatoes
and I understand that tomatoes and
lettuce have common Leighton factors
then even if I don't see you buy
tomatoes very much I can learn about
your price sensitive you may toes from
your price sensitivity for lettuce and
so that cross-product learning allows
you to get a lot more out of a data set
where people don't purchase things very
often so most consumers purchase most
products like 1% of the time so I think
that's gonna be also like a common theme
if you think about other types of
browsing and online data where most
consumers don't do most things very
often now at some level that insight you
guys already knew that because that's
sort of the inside of the Netflix
composition and matrix factorization so
you're gonna like what took you so long
in economics we didn't nobody tried it
so we're showing them that that works
and so I think and then the benefit
relatives a machine learning literature
for this is that actually there were a
bunch of a large number of computational
tweaks we needed to get to get this to
run at scale once you put in the
multinomial logit form we have the
softmax in the denominator and we have
these structural parameters so that was
kind of the part of the computational
thing really embedding it in the utili
maximization framework now I want to
talk about the last paper which in some
sense is is the most innovative
computationally although I'll go back
through a little bit of apologizing
because I would say that the model is
good but it's not the final model so in
this paper we've got the same data set
basically the same problem but now I
want to throw away my item information
and say I don't know how these products
relate to each other and further I want
to allow that some of them are actually
complements so the old model said paper
towels and tomatoes are just completely
separate they don't affect each other
and then we further assumed you're only
going to choose one paper towel or
you're only going to choose you know one
kind of tomato and we threw away things
where you buy bought a lot of like
multiple varieties of yoghurt we
actually threw away yoghurt now we're
gonna ask something can I figure out
that hot dogs and buns go together and
actually could I figure out that even
though water and juice are in different
categories those are actually also
imperfect substitutes can I learn all of
that from the data and so the privacy
started working on this problem in 1995
and I sort of solved it for two choices
and then we gave up because we weren't
able to go beyond three or four
computationally in the 90s of course if
I met all of you guys in the 90s that
were those of you who are still alive as
scholars you probably could have helped
me at that time but but you were born
yet as scholars in the 90s but but it
was it was still a hard problem so we
studied this and that the paper came out
actually it was pretty well cited paper
but we stopped with three or four
choices and so let me actually just skip
over that picture I'll just tell you
that there was a there's a very small as
I basically lifted like every economics
paper that's ever tried to estimate
complementarity between two or three
things and they've maxed out at three
roughly so you know I've got three
choices and I'm gonna see whether you
see this there's two to the three
there's eight bundles and I'm gonna try
to understand your preferences for those
eight bundles but of course these things
get very complicated very fast if I
wanted to go back and think I have five
thousand choices there's a question of
like well
wait a second not only is this hard to
compute for me but how the heck could
the consumer do it like I'm using a
utility maximization framework and I'm
trying to infer what the consumer was
doing when they maximized over to -
- to the 5000 bundles but isn't that
kind of idiotic some level right they
can't really do that so what we're gonna
probe you know take in this paper is
we're going to impose an arbitrary
heuristic on how the consumers shop and
then try to use that and estimate the
parameters of that heuristic the problem
with that is how am i heuristic and not
somebody else's heuristic and I would
say yeah that's a problem but I'm gonna
see if I get sensible things out of it
okay so what we're gonna do is we're
going to make a behavioral assumption
and and so when I say this is this is
not the last version we we have a bunch
of extensions that are in progress on
this but the basic behavioral assumption
is a myopic consumer goes into the store
considers sequentially what to buy and
they're going to go in order of
importance basically so we're gonna
start with the thing that's highest in
their utility from everything in the
store they're gonna put that into their
basket and then they're gonna say
alright what should I do next and then
they're gonna put the next thing in the
basket but when they put the next thing
in the basket they're going to consider
what's already in their basket so if
they have hot dog buns in their basket
they're gonna consider that when they
buy hot dogs and furthermore there's
gonna be a look ahead model so the
consumer is gonna look ahead to the next
item for now I have them look ahead to
the whole store although you could
imagine it's better for them to go
sequentially through sections of the
store or to think about things that go
together but anyways they're gonna look
right now and say I'm gonna look ahead
to the next item accounting for the
potential complementarity and of course
you might want to look ahead two or
three steps now hopefully a lot of you
were thinking huh sounds kind of like
reinforcement learning yeah exactly so
this is kind of fun and this is a
connection that I'd like to further
develop okay and then so there's a
latent item ordering because I don't
actually know what order they put things
in the basket but this behavioral model
implies a likelihood over orders
conditional on what you purchased
there's all likelihood over that orders
if you followed that behavioral model
and so I can actually infer that latent
variable as well and it's basically
because higher value items should have
been purchased earlier so
is our model so we still have the same
kind of functional form of utility we're
still gonna have loads of errors it each
time they make a choice but now we're
we're assuming this comp this possible
for complementarity in this look-ahead
model and so in the paper we write down
what this means for the probabilistic
model okay
so then just to get a sense of how this
works this is simulated data and so
we're gonna compare here a myopic model
where you just go through the store you
don't think ahead to a think ahead model
and we generated data about purchases
from all these products and we generated
the them according to preferences that
are kind of what you think so hot dogs
and hot dog buns or complements what
turns out in the data is it diapers and
coffee are highly positively correlated
I should pause there actually because
not everybody hears from economics so
there's this distinction between
correlation and complementarity which we
think about a lot in economics but it
may be those words were almost used
interchangeably if you're not used to
thinking about it so we would say that
coffee and diapers are complements if
you lower the price of coffee you would
buy more coffee and you'd buy more
diapers that means they're complements
because they go together
when you buy coffee you want more
diapers when you want when you buy
diapers you buy more coffee or similarly
if you you know raise the price of
coffee you would buy less diapers okay
if they're correlated it just means
there might be something about people
that make some like coffee and diapers
but if you go out of stock on coffee you
won't skip the diapers okay and so
that's actually a really important thing
because there's lots of stuff in the
data that's correlated right and and a
simple kind of just you know matrix
factorization won't be able to tell if
just peak coffee and diapers go together
because you need coffee to enjoy diapers
or if they go together because sleepless
people with babies need a lot of coffee
and so those things you can't tell the
difference in just a matrix
factorization approach how could you
possibly tell the difference well you
need data where the diapers go out of
stock or the diapers price goes up or
the diapers price goes down you actually
have to measure
whether when the price goes down people
respond in the other product and that's
that's the that's the key identification
strategy here so these these in this
simulation these up arrows show we
estimated a model and then we we
predicted what would happen if we
predict on to a test set that has higher
than usual prices of coffee and higher
than usual prices of taco shells and so
this is in the not think ahead model and
this isn't the think ahead model and so
we see in the not think ahead model the
myopic model when you raise the prices
of taco shells you still predict that
people buy taco seasoning because
they're gonna go and look for the taco
seasoning but they're not going to look
think ahead that the taco shells are too
expensive and so they don't want the
taco seasoning but in the look-ahead
model when the taco shells are expensive
you the model predicts that people won't
buy taco seasoning either because they
look ahead and they understand that they
they're not going to buy the taco shells
so yep example points out to me that the
likelihood function is going to depend
on this late in whatever that you're not
going to observe right yes see what you
infer it but it's I mean so them the the
behavioral model implies the you know
implies a probability distribution over
orderings but if we had a different
behavioral model that would in we can't
tell the difference between the
different behavioral models from the
data except for like by broad
goodness-of-fit measures so I guess I
didn't I still feel like there's going
to be potential identification problems
here where I can't tell the difference
between one unobserved ordering and one
ought observe set of preferences in a
different unobserved ordering the price
variation and out of stock variation
sufficiently should pin everything down
but I'm not going to argue that I have
that much price variation in my data set
go on to the store and look at where
things actually idea graphically and see
if that lines up with your learn yeah I
mean I think that the if you really
wanted to get into the level of detail
it would be good to have online browsing
data so that you could actually observe
the consumers behavior so let me just
show you a couple of other quick things
um so
here because this is we published this
we're publishing this in a to a
machine-learning audience and not to an
economics audience we have to have a lot
less descriptive statistics but here we
show the that our model does well and
what we do to try it instead of like the
other model where I have other paper
where we held out days with price
changes here we're just gonna look at
subsets of test data that have different
prices 20% 30% different prices and we
show that our model the relative
performance of our model it gets better
when we get to the more extreme prices
and these are different versions of
bottles that David Bligh is used like
hierarchical Poisson factorization and
various embedding models that he's used
from text and so he's showing that that
relative to David state-of-the-art
machine learning embedding models
incorporating the the price information
and in the complementarity and does
better when the prices are different
than average and that's what you're
hoping because we want to do well
predicting in unusual settings and so
then here's the we this is what we
discover so again when I told the I told
the model now nothing about what the
products were just the UPC s and we do
things like ah we discovered cheese and
we discovered baking and we discovered
fruit and we discovered toilet paper so
that's lovely so we can basically figure
out what the products are as well as
what substitutes and so just here the
the last slide I want to kind of give
some examples of the kinds of things you
can do here we're going to query the
data so if we query mission tortilla
soft tacos we can see which items are
the most complimentary according to our
estimated user preferences with Mission
tortillas soft taco and we find taco
shells taco seasoning and taco MIT taco
seasoning mix are the most complementary
with tough tacos hot dog buns yay there
are also complimentary with with with
these other hot dog buns which we then
could sort of think about maybe there's
like a taste for variety mustard is
complimentary with hamburger buns and so
on so I tell my kids like I worked for
three years and at the end of it I
discovered that my
shirred goes with hamburger buns so it's
some level like this is not the deepest
scientific discovery you'd ever want to
make but the idea would be that if you
think if your Amazon or Ebay and you
have these really big product
assortments and you don't really know
what kinds of things compete with each
other and what kinds of things go
together this could be helpful and in
particular analyzing one product the
time can be a problem because you you
give a sale on one product and it looks
like you're doing great but you've
actually stolen the demand from another
product or similar you have a sale on
one product and you're not you're under
estimating the benefit of getting people
to buy more of another product and so
those types of counterfactuals are
interesting so just to conclude I would
say I hope I have communicated
effectively that this is all a work in
progress the goal I hope was clear that
we want to be able to do these kinds of
Turner factual's the challenges maybe
are clear is that it's like it's
actually hard to convince people that
you've really identified the structural
parameters through the counterfactuals
and that's not just because I'm lame
it's because it's hard to find data that
actually has enough variation to figure
this stuff out but if you have big data
sets and you do have price changes and
you do have out of stock then you start
to learn enough to make this better and
so I would say the bigger research
agenda bringing together ideas from
reinforcement learning and inverse
reinforcement learning and matrix
factorization and econometrics is to be
able to help companies as well as like
customers are azor and others be able to
make these decisions
it gives me been shocked to find that in
three years okay some questions yeah so
did you do any doing a holdout
validation on any of these sets or
you're actually trying to validate on
the counterfactual so I think that the
if I think the one thing I would love to
see changes it's like the the machine
learning audience as I feel up and don't
have a lot of patience for like 30 or 40
pages of empirical analysis but in the
paper we have aim for the marketing
journal we spent more time trying to do
these holdout sets and really identify
you know here's here's days that are we
held out data from consumers in weeks
where there were price changes and then
we evaluated ourselves on how we fit for
those consumers on those weeks so yes so
the goal the goal is to tune and
evaluate yourself on held-out data on
weeks with changes is that so normally
the process would just be holdout data
how well do we predict is it is it any
different than saying well now we have
to hold out you know hold out
experiments or counterfactuals or is it
is it basically just that simple or
there are more things than you consider
when you were trying to well so I think
there's a couple of things first of all
you'd like to hold out experiments
absolutely and and in some sense you
want the experiments to be
representative of the ones that you
would do and they need to be different
from what's in your data but so that's
the first difference is and you want to
make sure that your testing changes the
second is what's your test statistic
because if I'm if my question is I want
to raise the price for all consumers
then my test statistic should be
something about predicting overall who
bought this product on this day and
that's actually more aggregated test
statistic and you actually make a
different bias-variance tradeoff for
that then if I said oh what I want to do
is send personalized coupons then my
test statistic would be about individual
responses to price changes and then you
would make a different bias variance
trade-off and so one of the things we
weren't really thinking about going in
we were thinking about just prediction
versus counterfactual and then we kind
of surprised ourselves because
let's just start by tuning for
prediction it'll be pretty similar but
it was actually like very different
numbers of latent variables and so on
depending on whether you wanted an
aggregate put an our aggregate test
statistic or a more micro one so that's
actually a little bit unsatisfying
though because it says like you have to
know the question you're asking
answering to choose a model and it's
harder to make a general-purpose model
so you can you go through what these
numbers are again just because it looks
like private friend hamburger buns are
top three compliments and top three
substitutes yes so this is actually so
this is not substitutes this is
something we called exchange ability so
it turns out that it was actually very
hard to identify substitutes in this in
data like this because basically most
stuff is just never purchased so it's
hard to tell that two things are
substitutes versus you just never bought
them and so what we actually introduced
a new concept which we call the I mean
it's not exchange ability is not a new
concept but as applied here which we
said two things are exchangeable if they
are if they're in two pairwise
interactions with all other products are
the same and there's two reasons things
could be exchangeable if they're always
bought together they would have the same
pairwise interactions with everybody if
they are never bought together they
would have the same pairwise
interactions with everybody so then the
idea is that if we take if we take
things that are exchangeable and they're
not complements maybe those are
substitutes because just empirically we
got a bunch of noise trying to identify
substitutes and that gets back to
modeling the zeros so another part of
our research agenda is to have better
modeling of the zeros which might help
us hone in on substitutes a little bit
more this remark you made about
basically different matrix leading to
different parameters being selected was
well I guess it when I saw that earlier
it made me a little bit nervous in the
sense that so you're relying to some
degree wrong so if you're getting some
reasonably good parameter identification
to make the predictions right you you
give not just relying on sir
having good predictive accuracy from the
model and to me if the answer is
changing based on the question you're
asking that to some degree revealing
there is non identifiability going on
with the parameters and so like you're
not learning quite the best once you can
from the data so let me speak that's a
deep deep question so I think in
economics this is partly why I think
people are gonna have some mixed
reactions to this are they there they I
generally fit smaller pot I thought
people might hate it in economics they
are actually liking it better than I
thought but there's some it's a real
wait a different way of thinking about
things we used to think there is one
true structural preference and I'm gonna
learn it and my theorem has to be when n
goes to infinity I learn it I nail it
I get precise confidence intervals I
know your preferences some level like
that just cute I mean how could I really
know what you feel about lettuce when I
saw you buy lettuce three times and so I
think there is a benefit to the machine
learning perspective which is it's all
an approximation and I just want to have
a better approximation and so that is a
slightly more pragmatic engineering
approach but you can only operationalize
it if you have a test set that lets you
it says how well do I do it what I care
about which then in some sense requires
you to have held out experiments because
if I can't if exactly as you say there
are many models that would equally fit
the data it's not they're not identified
whether you have ten latent factors are
50 or 70 I I don't know which one it is
I but I want to know what's the best
approximation to your preferences for
the purpose of doing a certain
counterfactual but it's very unappealing
that you have a different model for
different questions but it's it may be a
fact of nature but it's an unfortunate
fact of nature because you know and
having too many degrees of freedom in
the hands of the analysts and so on can
be problematic folks that pursue facts
of nature that they're looking for
though model what's really going on and
that's different than having a
predictive model or a task or a
counterfactual model you can actually
use in practice so it's different
between the foundations of science
sometimes I think that's what gets a
little bit deeper here right yeah no
it's a very yeah and I think that I
think that our search for the ground
truth of what people's preferences are
was a very vulnerable search but but
it's but what do I do if I have to make
a decision and I haven't seen you ten
thousand times with ten thousand
different prices for for lettuce and so
then I want to have a good approximation
to that so I think we have to I guess we
collectively are gonna have to figure
out how to marry these approaches and
make ourselves stay rigorous without
just saying what the economists said in
total today was I just can't try to
answer those questions oh sorry yeah
okay so we just take two more than we
can break it to like discussions around
the food the food area there so that you
get and so my question is about oh my
gosh is really short so you you
mentioned something along the lines of
like up statisticians and accommodations
are hesitant to take on variational
inference as like a method of doing
approximate inference do you get the
sense of like why is this hesitation
happening what could possibly be done to
kind of combat that and have you cut up
for example with variational inference
everything you're taking derivatives so
it's very like it's optimization based
so you can actually test like
sensitivity to your priors things like
that so I think they'd be more
confidence there sure I think I think
it's really just though that it's kind
of moving away I mean at the end because
you know you're getting approximation at
the end you have to mean in for
computational reasons you made a lot of
independence assumptions which you don't
really buy then it's some level you're
you're having to acknowledge the truth
which was always there to start with
which is that my model is an
approximation and I haven't actually
really found the ground truth of nature
along with that acknowledging that then
you need to add in all this other stuff
like how do I test the model how do I
evaluate the model which brings in a lot
of ambiguity so the world where we where
we could prove that we were going to
discover the true laws of nature and
eventually converge to it exactly Davis
didn't open up these cans of work now in
practice that you cut off the Markov
chain Monte Carlo after a month and you
know that it converge did it not you
know and I made 10,000 other assumptions
so that I could actually make my Markov
chain Monte Carlo run in a month and I
assumed this was linear
you know so I made all these other
assumptions so it's very schizophrenic
because I I made a zillion assumptions
but then I said I found the truth while
I'd say that I feel like the machine
learning approach is a little more like
it's all an approximation I'm gonna
admit that I can't figure out the truth
and then I'm going to focus a lot more
on testing and documenting the
performance and that's just harder for
counterfactual inference but it's I say
it's not impossible but I think my my
results today are kind of mixed like are
you completely convinced that I got
exactly the right parameters now you
shouldn't be or do you think that maybe
you could you know if you had a grid
enough data set hopefully I was going to
ask there was an example that one of my
mentors used to bring on as the first
slide which was if you have a laptop and
a backpack is suggested as a suggestion
that's that's when you're planning to
buy a laptop that's a reasonable
suggestion but if you're buying a
backpack for a laptop then suggesting
laptop seems stupid and that sort of
relates to the order question but also
it's like sort of a cause on question
and I'm wondering if your model actually
in any way in court like it's able to
recover that and like be suggested about
I would uh we made an assumption there
so we assumed you were gonna start with
the highest utility things first which
could be maybe it works with the laptop
and then the backpack and actually we
but that's but that's by assumption we
didn't discover that we assumed it and
maybe it may be actually a bunch of
these kind of silly examples have that
same feature that you start with the
most important thing but you know we
don't learn it and I think it would be
interesting to learn it but if I wanted
to learn that I wouldn't treat it all as
a big latent variable I would actually
get data from an online shopping so I
could actually observe it because I
think it's the point that you're trying
to model at that level of detail you
should get the data
[Applause]
you